I gotta ask about Ron DeSantis is it do
who uh he's just he's this guy I don't
know if you heard of Honey D he's over
in Florida uh he hasn't announced but
obviously everyone thinks he's gonna run
what do you think do you think obviously
you don't think he's gonna win because
Trump's going to win well listen
um you're asking my honest opinion and I
would tell you and right now you know in
this moment in time I think thousand
percent Trump is going to you know win
the primary he will be the nominee and I
don't see anybody I mean do you I mean
let me know no I completely agree let me
know if you you know anybody or think
that there's anybody on the left that
can beat Trump in the general election
if you have a legitimate election where
votes are cast and one vote one whatever
just saying right how the whole system
works and I go and put my vote down
there you go ma'am thank you so much
boom boom boom boom boom who who now
that you have buying an office and you
have that juxtaposition and you see what
he has done have been a total abysmal
failure nor did I expect anything else
because he doesn't have the business
Acumen or the experience he's not a CEO
he's not a businessman he is a failed
career politician of 50 years sponging
off the backs of the taxpayers that guy
that dog don't hunt okay there we go
then you you've got Kamala Harris who I
worked with in the DA's office all right
now the whole world knows what I already
knew okay that she is completely
incapable incompetent and actually kind
of Fright Night terrifying attack like
it's not good the cackling laugh and
whatever Halloween should just come one
time a year didn't you not even get it
who wants any of this I think you want
California Kamala didn't even get one
delegate right Chelsea gabber got one
pretty sure I like her the only person
that could beat Trump is Michelle Obama
I don't know if she has any aspiration
to even do it but she's just famous and
has that name right there was people
like Michelle Obama I don't even know if
I buy that anymore because we're in such
a highly politicized time the Obamas
succeeded like vastly on the idea that
we just didn't talk about how bad things
were at the time and if you're not
politically aware and you're not paying
attention to what's going on you just
assume that everything is going good
nothing that is partially to do with the
fact that the media pushed what we would
call now globalism but was a neoliberal
policies on the world so you just
assumed if you weren't paying attention
to politics that everything was going
good The World Isn't like that anymore
we're highly we're highly highly divided
right now I think if the election were
held right now Donald Trump would win
based on the economy uh and that's the
the biggest Factor based on what's going
on with Ukraine the wars we're at a
point what happened in Afghanistan
absolutely
and and Trump said all of this was going
to happen when he was campaigning and
and here we are now I think it's you you
can get a Joe Biden in when no one knows
what to expect but now we know exactly
what to expect and it's apocalyptic
Trump's going to walk into back remember
2019 member of the economy remember how
much money you made I'm gonna bring it
back and they're going to be like yes
please remember graphene to that point
this is it with all the dustrials with
all the talk about Rhonda Santos I don't
see him being able to get anywhere near
close here's the deal Rhonda Santos uh
you know if I got you know and his wife
good job I know yeah I know them very
well Don Jr and I and the president
campaigned uh you know vigorously for
them raising money all of the above when
he was very down at the poll so Trump's
just like bro like I helped you out you
know I did a great job for you you we're
gonna lose to this freak Show guy down
there and I helped you and you know God
bless how about this
be smart be a strategist you're doing a
good job in Florida why don't you
continue to actually do your job in
Florida
Trump is going to run he smashed 16
insanely qualified candidates in 2016. I
mean smashed them to living hell okay
hilariously hilariously I mean it's like
oh that one low energy jab he just fell
off the stage like whatever and then now
you're gonna think you're gonna go in
you're not like I'm telling you this guy
and I was the first one to support him
at Fox because I knew the man like I
said you know he's my friend for 18
years I know the measure of the guy I
know what he's capable of I know that he
is somebody that you're not going to be
able to like defeat you can't break this
guy you cannot no matter what happens I
think he's made from a different whole
kind of like DNA why don't you just run
like do your office and then run be the
appointed one of the you know Maga
movement Etc et cetera the populist
movement the America first movement
instead of now you're putting yourself
up in front of a firing squad of people
who are literally so pro-trump because
Trump actually did a good job we don't
wonder about the job that he did he did
a great job do you want someone going in
there with like you know like training
wheels on to try to fix this mess that
they made or do you want a guy that you
know that can actually do the job and
kick ass or someone who's respected what
about from National Security perspective
okay because the rest of her making a
joke out of us look at North Korea look
at crazy go get a little rocket man he's
going nuts uh you know Vlad a lot of
cats going nuts no one cared they're
like laughing at the United States the
NATO's like no one cares because there's
nobody of any substance whatsoever this
guy was sitting there talking about chop
chocolate chip ice cream when children
were murdered is that the leader you
want in the white house that's what I'm
saying so that's what I'm telling you
vice president's gonna win I think
Trump's going to win too all right vice
president I I so I don't know that I
would there was a period where I said
Rhonda said this maybe now I'm thinking
I said carry a lake maybe but I'm seeing
a lot of people be like no she's too
like Trump and you need kind of that
contrast I don't know she's a female I
think Minnie she's not that like him
this is this is what I was saying about
um the extradition threat me indictment
against Donald Trump Ron DeSantis
statement was very disappointing to me I
think he's done a great job in Florida I
think he's done a lot of really
tremendous things that's why so many
people moved there so many people voted
for him but he said look I'm not going
to get involved in this and my response
was the governor should have said mark
my words you will not lay a hand on
Donald Trump in my state and Carrie Lake
would have said that you tweeted uh
Trump 2024. oh yeah absolutely I saw it
I retweeted it I retweeted I checked my
feet I was I was a year ago I was like I
think DeSantis but things change and
what the problem I had was all I saw
from Trump was 2020 2020 just kept
talking about it and so I was just like
I don't see anything here I know that
annoyed people but now you'd be pissed
if you thought that you know something
was taken from you and that you thought
both were counted that sure you know
weren't real or actual or you know
saying that's a whole other thing if
that's what he thinks I understand his
feelings but all that mattered to me now
is especially seeing East Palestine
going down there buying McDonald's for
people was a grand slam absolutely
seeing him put out these videos where he
talks about policy policies that I
actually care about you like those
policy videos I think they're very good
absolutely he has specifics it's not
just uh you know flowy rhetoric in 2020
around August I said okay I'm gonna vote
for this guy I didn't vote for him the
first time I said earlier I probably
wouldn't vote for him but when he
released his second term agenda I was
like okay this is pretty good the school
choice was huge getting rid of the
critical race Theory and government
contracts all of that stuff and so now
him putting out these policy videos I'm
like
You Know Carl Benjamin of the Lotus
Eaters podcast hit me up and he says Tim
you're wrong about DeSantis Trump has to
finish his narrative Arc let me explain
and he's got this video where he breaks
down Trump's story is not over he has a
mission to accomplish and that did mean
something to me and then when I saw
everything you know the campaigning he's
begun doing I thought his announcements
which was actually good A lot of people
were like I didn't like it I thought it
was good I thought the videos you put
out were great and then what really put
me over the 50 Mark was when he bought
McDonald's for people and he said I know
about the menu better than you do and
then everyone's laughing and I'm like
that that is a total fact by the way a
lot of times I've had McDonald's with
him and I have McDonald's today and were
we not laughing about it and talking
about okay what is djt like I'm like
okay well he likes to get the chicken
nuggets like it's a fish sandwich like I
said the quarter pounder with the cheese
this is what we eat it's good huh oh I
fueled myself up with it today but I
just think I don't touch that you know
when when when not all of it but I don't
like the bread yeah I'm not gonna eat
McDonald's but when he bought all the
McDonald's for everybody at the White
House for that sporting thing you know
that's that that is personable it's
relatable when he went to East Palestine
I thought to myself uh we had Benny
Johnson on Benny said Joe Biden
literally went to the furthest part of
the globe he went
on the other side of the planet from
Ohio right and then my response was hey
look and on President's Day Marianne
Williamson announces she's running I
think she's a very nice lady she did not
go there the vague ramaswami I think
he's brilliant he's a man he's amazing
yeah he didn't go there either is that
who you want yeah
and so I'm thinking even take it back to
the nest these these other people who
are running for president didn't bother
to go to East palestinos it's big in the
news these people's lives are destroyed
and Trump's like I'm going down there
even if you thought it's a PR stunt and
that's what some people in the corporate
left press were saying they were like
Trump's playing politics it's a stunt
and I'm like oh so if I vote for a guy
my worst case scenario is in an attempt
to to uh earn favor with the public
he'll do good things to him he'll do the
right thing and I can tell you it wasn't
I'll take it because he's not a stunt
kind of guy he actually was like this is
outrageous this guy's not going or
what's wrong with this guy that's how he
talks and then he's like I'm gonna go
there then he's gonna buy people
McDonald's loves McDonald's he loves
Pizza Hut and I'll try to like throw
like props up but I'm just telling you
what he eats he likes that a lot and we
went to the Kentucky huh no Papa John's
well your new pizza thing yeah oh yeah
me and Jack was over we're gonna open a
pizza restaurant yeah you know stay
tuned I'll build a recipe
Midtown delicious pepperoni pizza in the
American Girl dolls they've released
like a 90s Classics Edition it's got the
Pizza Hut cups that you always talk
about the the 90s cups the Red Cups I
thought um he likes that in Kentucky
Fried Chicken just say when the Kentucky
uh Derby and I said it's very good we're
gonna go back we're gonna get the
Kentucky Fried Chicken so we had a total
Feast of that we have to be careful I
want your service is gonna have to jump
in front of his diet
they're running the Kentucky Fried
Chicken you know people finding
relatable billionaire but he wants to
eat but he wants to eat that's what all
things aside that's in shape all things
aside I want to see Trump's Revenge I
want to see him debate like a real
debate where they don't hate each other
they just are straightforward like him
and it is the sanus whatever vivek's
great because he's smart he can talk
about economics because he needs I think
Trump he doesn't need it but humility if
you show him like weak for a moment and
then he's able to still find the right
way through the weekend he's gonna do it
I want a little debates with like
Hillary Clinton when she tried to hit
him with the tax credits you had a
chance to get rid of him and he even all
your donors are benefiting from it so
yeah some of them are pretty bad like
but you should have done something about
it to change it so they're on the books
I took advantage of it next question I
want to see in 2024 Trump get revenge I
want him on who give me the list of
Vengeance man I don't like it no no no
no no Donald Trump wins and they
immediately start accusing him of being
a Russian they run this massive
ridiculous nonsense investigation which
was just Bonkers they accuse him of
doing what Joe Biden did with the quid
pro quo in Ukraine they they put they
strapped weights to his ankles and we
still had what Jim Cramer called the
best numbers of Our Lives despite that
guy's got no credibility but it was so
good even he couldn't have been wrong
which is kind of funny so 2019 we saw
this really great economy despite all
the things they were doing to weigh him
down I want to see Donald Trump get in
and actually care at his agenda
untethered and then fire all of these
people right and get the job done that
he was supposed to get done a lot of
people said he didn't drain this one
well a lot of people said he did and all
it did was expose the swap monsters
standing in the field the next thing
thing he needs to do is fire them all I
I don't disagree but just so you
understand this man works like
um I don't know 18 out of 24. I know
he's up super late he's you know awake
very early he is constantly working
constantly writing this stuff down and
he is literally just waiting for that
day of reckoning you just wait and see
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time